da freut sich doch jeder veganern spitze
oder meist ungehört den zogen
das geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute ich hab mir
natürlich geht es gut ich muss sagen wir
drehen gerade zwei videos innerhalb von
ein zwei stündchen wir haben gerade
schon den amerikanischen adventskalender
komplett leer gemacht und ich hoffe ihr
habt das video dazu natürlich alles
schon gesehen
den kennt er ja schon falls nicht schaut
euch nach diesem video an
denn heute machen wir einen weiteren
kalender auf ich bin sehr gespannt was
heute kommt wir haben doch im kalender
aus den 80ern und veganen
adventskalender und ich würde sagen
bislang nahmen einfach mal einen
aussuchen oder links rechts links
haben sie schon gesehen was los so ist
es ich sage es einfach 24 vegane
überraschungen und hier muss ich auch
wieder sagen leute also ich finde die
designs von entega ich heftig komme
sogar mit einem ticket hier dein kauft
einen sozialen beitrag ja gut das haben
wir ja schon im ersten video erläutert
das sind alles keine die von menschen
mit handicap befüllt werden also da
wären arbeitsplätze für diese menschen
beschaffen deswegen hier schon morgen
wieder unten noch nach oben und auch
unten nach oben für dieses design da
freut sich doch jeder veganern schnitzel
oder meist junge hat den zonen da hat zu
mir kann ja darauf reagieren wird mit
mx-5 insel runter als verbot bunter
regenbogen und ja also veganer
adventskalender
ich muss sagen ich bin kein veganer
ich esse auch nicht mehr so viel fleisch
wie früher aber ab und zu mal einen
burger oder so trotzdem sind
wahrscheinlich jetzt mehr veganer hier
heute auf dem video als zweimal in
anderen videos weil es ja um vegane
sachen geht
ich habe aber damals schon mal eine
woche wegen gelebt da habe ich sehr viel
lob übrig auch von vielen wegen und ich
finde es übrigens gut dass veganer gibt
und dass es immer mehr veganer gibt und
vielleicht bin ich auch irgendwann
vegetarier zumindest das habe ich mir
den kopf gesetzt dass bald zu schaffen
naja gut anderes thema wir wollen jetzt
ja gar nicht soviel wir drauf rumreiten
deswegen würde ich sagen machen war die
noch direkt mal auf ne er warte mal was
das denn hier kann man denn hier
aufklappen hält könnten komplett auf
machen
muss ja gehen um den zu befüllen da was
man testen hast du musst ihn kaputt
machen würde
woher kommen wir lassen alte dann würde
ich sagen
fangen wir an weil er einst auch sonst
ich bin jetzt echt mal gespannt ob wir
so süßigkeiten drin sind oder generell
vegane lebensmittel veganer cacau
veganes kakaopulver das mache ich mir
jetzt sorgen doch schön milch ist denn
kakao nicht gerne halten vegan der wird
doch einfach nur da kann man nicht das
ist okay ich habe auch keine ahnung aber
bevor man nach was sollte sein
cacau wird doch einfach angebaut na ja
wir lassen das mal so im raum stehen
leute bitte seit so sanft würde uns ihr
könnt sie einen kommentar schreiben
wenn es bis ich sehe schon um will ja
denke mal zwei wollen wir die weitere
hier ja ich muss immer so verkehrt so
was haben wir hier
kakoko die vegane kekse oder amazon hat
sein apple cinema - naja gut die nummer
drei biomarker pulver weiter die vier
habe ich dann eben schon gesehen
ich muss sagen das ist wirklich das
finde ich jetzt gerade noch
interessanter als den letzten
adventskalender weil ich die meisten
produkte so noch nie gesehen hat traut
berger bio mango aber weiter oder möchte
einen kurzen snack für zwischendurch
ich probiere mal kurz eine bio man
schmeckt so gut dass beide veganer
werden
das gut getrocknet aber ist es nicht so
meint ein bisschen wie das ok machen
aber weiter die nummer fünf
ist ja irgendwie interessant dass alles
so eingepackt ist in so typen bio
studentenfutter wert zwar nicht den
ganzen kalender ausgepackt aber ich
hätte jetzt irgendwie mit anderen sachen
gerechten alex cooper da die nummer
setzt nicht voraus dass veganer
bitterschokolade ja gut war was anderes
mit einer tüte machen wir weiter mit der
nummer 7 er war was man mal sagen muss
die ganzen typen sind
wiederverschließbar das fehlt halt bei
jeder sonstigen scheiße stimmt da hast
du recht nein aber du kannst deine
sachen einfach zu machen der
gummibärchen sind die einfach auf buy ja
du hast recht analysten sind die eltern
oft hast du zufällig irgendwo die sieben
gesehen aber ich hab sie hier
laut berger also was haben wir hier bio
spirulina pulver was ist das zieht man
sich durch die namen sind doch kein
partys geil ist aber vegan sogar etwas
ist weiß ich nicht aber das ist
wahrscheinlich irgendwas zum kochen oder
müssen hier passiert ich mag ist es
nicht schlimm nicht sicher was ist das
muss zu empfehlen ist nicht schlimm wie
ist das nochmal spiri nun sparen die
käufer keine ahnung ich bereite mich
jetzt mal bist du nicht mal
hintereinander auf hier den 19 bio
datteln passt ja eben gesagt kommt wir
sind da drin ist ja auch noch für die
nicht begangen er ganz interessant zum
video zu sehen aber mix wieder ähnlich
wie studentenfutter hier haben wir
schokoladenpudding pulver mit
aromatischen cargo könnte ich jetzt
wieder die gleiche frage stellen aber
lasse ich besser so hier haben wir
wieder diese granada - diesmal mit
strawberry eben hatten wir apple genau
das ist zucchini linse mit oregano the
cherry
wenn man nochmal der probiere ich auch
direkt mal oder ich mag es doch wie geht
also das auge isst mit
die doppelbestrafung vorfeld überhaupt
nicht austrinken einfach was war das
also bis jetzt muss ich leider sagen ich
bin noch nicht der größte fan dieses
kalenders der andere war besser ich bin
auch mit den produkten ich habe da
irgendwie klar hätte man sich denken
können dass man mehr so was drin ist
aber vielleicht ist das ja nur bei mir
so also an sich schon ein paar coole
sachen dabei so keine frage an die
veganer ihr könnt ja gerne mal die
kommentare schreiben
würdet ihr sonnenkalender feiern also
weil ich kann das ganz schlecht
beurteilen
bio kürbiskern checkt auf jeden fall das
andere video ab durch den ersten
kalender aufgemacht habe ich bin mir
auch sicher beim nächsten jetzt wieder
besser aber hier bin ich das irgendwie
noch nicht so ganz überzeugt
bio maulbeeren klingt ja eigentlich so
an sich ganz süß zeigen wir wie die
aussehen
[Applaus]
manchmal denk dir ansehen wie dieses mal
gewinnen also hier kann man auf jeden
fall gut essen das so lieber 15 bio bio
goji beeren einfach mal was anderes
sehen was gelbes bio soja snack tomaten
chili da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wenn
da mehr solche sachen drin werden so was
ich weiß nicht es auch ein bisschen
schwierig zu erklären
ich glaube dann würde ich mehr feiern
[Applaus]
aber er kommt das ist jetzt interessant
für mich weil ich so was halt vor sowas
habe ich zum beispiel noch nie gegessen
so patrick duffy 21 sagt die 18 sagt die
23 24 fans ganz viel gold vergessen
für die 24 auch machen haben wir hier
spirulina zitrone das ist jetzt mal
interessant das war nämlich eben dieses
dinge was ich da an meinen händen hatte
spirulina pulver ich kann es immer noch
nicht aussprechen doch violine und ich
stelle mir einfach vor das lecker ist es
gar nicht so schlecht schmeckt sehr
fruchtig deutlich wichtiger ist das
spiel culina habe ich noch nie gehört
aber geschmeckt interessant
wahrscheinlich gibt es hat noch nie
gehört habe ist das normal wenn man das
noch nie gehört also nicht klug and
sound ist ja gut dann haben wir es zu
guter letzt noch die nummer 24
da ist jetzt was ganz krasses drin
jetzt kommen sie jetzt kommen sie mal
raus gesprungen
keiner nahm als karla neumarkt seit
kennt man doch das ist eine mischung aus
salz und dem feinsten kux das ist eine
mischung aus salz und kali lama ist vor
allem in den gebirgigen halten
afrikas sehr beliebt sollte das war's
mit video ich muss sagen auch nicht sehr
sehr interessanter kalender auf jeden
fall ein paar sachen habe ich neu
probiert manches fand ich eher weniger
geist der letzte kalender aber auf jeden
fall meine meinung nach cooler checkt
das video open habt dann habe ich jeden
fall am boxi denn du führst zur
verfügung stellen
ich habe euch den kalender in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und wir sehen uns
morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt es ein
neues video aber nicht den kanal aktive
die glocke und schreib mir weitere
kalender die tasten soll
haut rein vegan
[Musik]